have you seen uh the bare knuckle fights
I did I watched it recently yeah okay
thoughts I wouldn't do that [__]
there was it was Eddie Alvarez said
something really interesting he's like
this is not for the athletes this is
awesome yeah shout out Mike Perry bro
yeah this guy's so [__] funny in
other words so entertaining but uh and a
tough dude yeah but um but yeah I wonder
if
I wonder if we're just drawn to the most
Savage form of combat
that is not murder yeah and because I
remember ordering it up on my [__]
phone
I think I was just finished a show or
something like that and I was just like
I just got to see what happens in this
and it lives up to it and I'm curious
like you you wouldn't do it no 100 now
why not uh I like and I like the
athletic chess game of of fighting to
where like Eddie says for the dog that's
just like who's the
you know some I don't know it's just but
didn't you have a problem with UFC when
you first saw I didn't think it was too
brutal when you did when I was like I
remember being like 10 11 12 something
around that age group my dad was
watching fighting and I thought it was
[__] up and my Mom hated it too and I
wanted to watch something else on the TV
so I was like Mom dad's watching
fighting again and my mom's yelling my
dad change it but I remember yeah I was
like I don't understand how they can
kick each other in the ribs and punch
each other in the face and how that I
just didn't get it as a sport which is
really [__] crazy to think about now
but I remember that vividly like telling
on my dad for watching you yeah so
I
think it
pencil to you know do grow
but I don't know if it's gonna peek out
much bigger than it is right now it
seems like all of the biggest bare
knuckle matches are still kind of
drafting off of UFC Fame right so it's
almost like uh watching Cristiano
Ronaldo he's a soccer player I know you
don't [__] with that [__] but uh but
watching him play in Saudi Arabia it's
like we're still gonna watch but it's
maybe not the the peak level but it is a
fascinating thing to see because at the
end of it in the press conference is
like their hands are gone yeah how many
times can you fight like you're gonna
break your hand probably everything
every single fight yeah how many times
can you do that I I would assume
I think it happens like I think you do
that
you can't break your hand 10 [__]
times just keep doing it I think if they
get better with The Branding and
promotion that grows just as big if not
bigger than yours interesting really
well think about how many times you open
your social media and watch a flight a
street fight how entertaining the [__]
yeah yeah that's a bare knuckle fight
yeah the broken hand thing is a good
point but what I was thinking initially
is boxers probably thought about UFC
this is barbaric there's not a chest
remember the early days it was kind of
like a sideshow and also they I mean
everybody would fight everybody yeah
fat guy skinny guy is always fun yeah
but to that point that could happen with
bare knuckle boxes I didn't think about
the broken hand thing yeah you can only
break your handsome I'm with you I think
the genius of of UFC obviously has top
athletes now but there really are
curating the identities of fighters in a
way that like boxing completely messed
up it's clear that Dana came from boxing
and these guys came from boxing they're
like what's wrong with this
and
I do understand that there are people
that like push back and there are people
that are upset about the structure of it
but at the same time if you're willing
to do what you're doing what is he's
doing what Connor did you can make
unbelievable amounts of money and have
unbelievable success there's a there is
a an organization dedicated to making
you look amazing yeah cutting clips of
every single thing you do yeah in boxing
you got to do that yourself you gotta
hire your video team you're gonna do it
the UFC if you knock somebody out please
believe it is on SportsCenter oh [__]
8K everywhere yeah so I think that is a
good now I know it seems like I'm
Shilling for the UFC but I I come from
boxing where I've seen these guys who
are spectacular maybe they don't speak
English and they don't have a [__]
shot dude yeah unless they have a team
like a powerful management team that can
hire those people promote them get them
on different platforms they don't have a
[__] shot man
yeah that sucks that's what I'm saying
about when I was coming up in the UFC
not necessarily getting paid like what
people like oh you should be making this
but yeah I'm all right they're giving me
this crazy [__] platform and they're
gonna get your money and I'm gonna get
exactly I'm gonna get it and uh but yeah
no I agree UFC Dana those guys [__]
know what they're doing yeah but bare
knuckle they they very well could like
grow but